hey everyone I'm Dan for Fandango movie
clips and these are 13 things you didn't
know about the original poltergeist
including the fact that maybe peed my
pants
number one poltergeist originally had an
r-rating but after protesting Steven
Spielberg and director Toby Huber got it
to PG even though the film features
smoking up with kids a guy ripping his
face off and swimming with corpses my
mom still doesn't let me watch that
stuff number two Steven Spielberg
couldn't officially direct poltergeist
because he was contractually obligated
to et the extra-terrestrial but because
of et's production delays Spielberg made
it to the poltergeist set for most their
shoot days poltergeist and et were
released within 1 week of each other in
June of 1982 the back-back Spielberg
hits led Time magazine to call it the
Spielberg summer was really like this
field for a decade or the Spielberg
century like Spielberg owns our lives
number four the creepy stacked chair
sequence was done in one shot when the
camera follows Diane's view away from
the table the crew quickly replaced the
four chairs with a pre-arranged chair
pyramid Zelda Rubinstein who played
tangina the psychic claimed to actually
be able to see things before they happen
which is odd because even though she
could see the future she still did
poltergeist three number six the
skeletons they used in poltergeist were
real skeletons what special effects
artist Craig Rearden said it was cheaper
to purchase real skeletons than it was
to create plastic ones yeah guys we're
good to go in the 360-degree rotating
bedroom an 8-foot demon head but the
plastic skeletons those are going to
bring us over budget let's bring in the
corpses number seven
Spielberg's premise for poltergeist was
based on the history of Cheesman Park in
Denver Colorado
that's a park that was constructed over
a cemetery apparently building over
cemeteries is more common than you
thought so good luck sleeping tonight
number eight the scene where a ghost
drags Diane to the ceiling was achieved
through a rotating box with a stationary
camera these and other amazing special
effects helped land poltergeist an Oscar
nomination for Best Visual Effects but
they lost to ET
number nine the poltergeist films are
rumored to be cursed because of the four
cast member deaths that took place over
the course of the three films but this
is supposed to be a fun video so let's
move on to number 10
the poltergeist lighting effects
involved flashing lights through fish
tanks Spielberg wanted to like to have a
living vibrant look and shooting light
two aquariums did the job number eleven
poltergeist is one of the few Spielberg
films that does not feature a John
Williams score instead Spielberg got
composer Jerry Goldsmith to do it that
score was good enough to land
poltergeist an Oscar nomination for Best
Original Score but they lost to ET
number 12
actress Jobeth Williams claims that each
day after arriving home from said she
found the pictures on her wall
mysteriously crooked or maybe you just
live on a hill Jobeth you ever think of
that
and finally number 13 the scary tree in
creepy clown doll were both fears that
Spielberg had as a child but things that
scare Steven Spielberg have a really
good track record for making great films
scary dolls dinosaurs man-eating sharks
handsome globe-trotting explorers all
fears that led to classics so there you
have it the horror phenomenon
poltergeist perhaps the most exciting
memorable film of 1982 if it weren't
free tea I'm Dan for Fandango movie
clips thanks for watching and remember
to see the new poltergeist in theaters
soon let's see the old Pope gets to see
both poltergeist have a poltergeist
party hold it guys super super bonanza
holder guys time
you